- We're asked what is the
constant of proportionality
between Y and X in the graph?
And just as a reminder,
when we're talking about
constant of proportionality,
it sounds like a very fancy thing,
but it's not too bad.
If we're thinking about
any X-Y pair on this,
on this line, let's say, right over here.
We have some X comma Y.
If Y is proportionate,
or is proportional to X,
then that means we can say that
Y is equal to some constant.
Y is equal to some constant times X.
And that constant, that is our
constant of proportionality,
right over there.
Sometimes you'll see this expressed,
if you divide both sides by X,
sometimes you'll see this as Y over X,
is equal to the constant
of proportionality.
It shows for any X-Y pair, if
you take your Y divided by X,
what do you get?
That's the same, same thing.
So with that out of the way,
see if you can answer their question.
What is the constant of proportionality
between Y and X in the graph?
Well they very clearly give
us a point right over here,
this point is the point
three, three comma two.
And so we could set it up a few ways.
We could say, look when Y is equal to two,
X is equal to three, and so
two would need to be equal to
some constant of
proportionality times three.
And if you wanted to solve for this,
you just divide both sides by the three.
So divide both sides by three,
and you would get your
constant of proportionality
is two-thirds.
Another way to do it, right over here.
Well here, we've kind
of already solved for
our constant of proportionality.
When Y, or we could say, when X is three,
when X is three, Y is equal to two.
In either case, our
constant of proportionality
is two-thirds.
Let's do another example.
So here we have which line has
a constant of proportionality
between Y and X of five over four.
So pause the video and see
if you can figure that out.
So the key realization
is we should test points
on these lines, we should test X-Y pairs,
and say, look if we
take our Y divided by X,
do we get five-fourths?
Because that would be our
constant of proportionality.
So let's first try, let's
try line A right over here.
So line A, let me find
a point that sits on it.
so that looks like a
point that sits on it.
And so if I take, this is
the point two comma five.
And so if I took Y divided by X,
I would get a constant of
proportionality as five halves.
So A is not going to be our answer.
We wanna get to a constant
of proportionality
of five-fourths.
Alright, let's try B. Okay
B, let me find a point on B.
Looks like this is a point on B.
That is the point four
comma five, four comma five.
And so in this situation, K
would be our Y, which is five,
divided by our X, which is four.
So it looks like B is our choice.
For kicks, you could also look at the
constant of proportionality
right over here.
Now there is one interesting example
that I just wanna touch on
before we finish these examples.
What about a situation
where Y is equal to X?
What is the constant of
proportionality then?
And what would it look like as a line?
Pause this video and think about it.
Well, there's really nothing new here.
It's just, you might not really see
the constant of proportionality
when you see it expressed this way.
But Y is equal to X, is the same thing as
Y is equal to one times X.
And so then it might jump out at you that
the constant of proportionality is one
in this scenario right over here.
Or if you took Y divided by X, Y over...
Let me do it in that black color.
Or if you took Y over X,
you divided both sides by X,
you would be left with the
constant of proportionality,
which would be equal to one.
And if you wanted to graph it,
well it would just look like this.
Y would be equal to X, for all X's.
So that's what when your
constant of proportionality
is one, you would...
Those would represent
points on this orange line
that I just constructed.